é
[Música]
a primeira vez que eu me sente frustrada
com o mundo era um dia qualquer que eu
estava caminhando com minha mãe na rua
quando eu percebi que diversos homens
estava olhando para o bumbum dela
naquele momento eu acho que o que mais
me incomodou foi perceber que eles
estavam olhando para o corpo dela do
mesmo jeito que meu eu de oito anos
olhava para uma fatia de bolo hoje eu
vou falar sobre feminismo na sociedade
pós-moderna o feminismo ele é um
movimento que luta por direitos
equânimes entre os gêneros e também pela
empoderar a emancipação feminina que
juntos levaram à queda do patriarcado o
patriarcado sendo a constante e
dominação masculina nas estruturas de
poder eu sei que essa frase pode ter
parecido um pouco pesada ou até mesmo
complicada de se entender mas o que ela
quer dizer é basicamente nos estamos
cansados de sermos tratados como
inferiores
simplesmente por sermos mulheres
estamos cansadas de diariamente sermos
objetificadas e sexualizadas ouvindo
piadas e inclusivas e cantadas
grosseiras de desconhecidos na rua
estamos cansados de ser normalizado o
machismo que é o sensível de
masculinidade e também a misoginia que é
o ódio ou aversão a mulheres ouvindo
frase direcionadas a homens como por
exemplo para de ser tão menininha e
também Nossa você perdeu para uma mulher
nós estamos cansadas de saber que a cada
11 minutos uma mulher ou garota é
estuprada isso só no Brasil somos
olharem dados globais uma em cada três
mulheres sofre ou já sofreu violência
sexual isso segundo dados da OMS
estamos cansados estávamos e ainda
estamos e decidimos fazer algo este algo
sendo feminismo desde que me conheço por
gente e desde a primeira vez que ouvi
falar sobre feminismo e me considero
feminista sabe quando alguém te conta
uma coisa maravilhosa e você se
identifica com quilo você pensa nossa eu
quero isso para minha vida então fui eu
com feminismo mas eu tenho que admitir
que não importava quantas injustiças
contra a mulher eu visse na rua na
escola outra mesmo a minha própria casa
eu não falava nem fazer nada ele ficava
parada me sentindo frustrada por dentro
observando a quilos em mim por parte
disso o que eu achava que era nova
demais nova demais para falar alguma
coisa nova demais para mim por para
falar que aquilo estava errado mas parte
disso também acontecia porque eu tinha
medo ou até mesmo vergonha de falar que
eu era feminista e alguém Vem Me
Completar sobre isso porque eu não sabia
Eu não sentia que eu sabe o suficiente
sobre movimentam eu sabia os objetivos
eu sabia Pelo que a gente tá voltando
mas eu não sabia como a gente alcançar
esses objetivos e não também não
conhecia os anos os séculos de história
que vinham antes de mim eu pensei que
uma literal pandemia me atingisse para o
realmente sentar não escrevaninha por
meu cérebro pra funcionar e finalmente
pesquisar tudo aquilo que eu tinha tanta
necessidade de saber eu li livros
artigos e ensaios diversos vídeos e
depois de tudo isso e um pouco mais eu
finalmente saciei aquela vontade aquela
necessidade de conhecimento que eu tinha
e acabei me deparando com muito mais há
séculos as mulheres vêm lutando por
Equidade nas os bom e com essa
consistente luta nós conseguimos o
espaço de fala a importância na
sociedade que nós temos hoje e diversos
direitos também algumas conquistas das
mulheres brasileiras por exemplo são em
1827 o direito à educação básica o
direito de ir às escolas e 1879 o
direito à educação superior o direito de
ir à faculdade somente em 1932 o direito
a votar esse é um dos que mais me
surpreendi surpreendia Por que estranho
pensar que eu convivi com pessoa a minha
bisavó que apesar de ser adulta não
podia votar
Voltando às conquistas somente
1962 as mulheres foram permitidas
trabalhar e também viajar sem a
permissão de seu marido ou pai somente
em 1974 foi permitido que mulheres
tivessem um cartão de crédito e uma
conta bancária somente em
e foi tirado da constituição que
mulheres não podiam praticar esportes e
somente em 1980 as forças armadas
aceitaram o ingresso de mulheres
e somente em
1985 foi criada a primeira delegacia da
mulher
somente em
1988/1988 a 40 e Poucos Anos Atrás as
mulheres foram finalmente considerados
iguais aos homens perante a Constituição
Federal agora na atualidade somente em
2002 a virgindade da esposa parou de
pertencer a seu marido somente em 2006
foi sancionada a Lei Maria da Penha
somente em 2015 foi sancionada a Lei do
feminicídio e somente em 2018 foi
sancionada a Lei da importunação sexual
muitas pessoas acham como eu também
achava que o feminismo é algo da
atualidade mas mulheres como a inglesa
Mary wollstonecraft
é que era escritora filósofa e defensora
dos direitos das mulheres e também como
a Francesa olympe de gouges que através
de sua que era dramaturga defensora dos
direitos das mulheres
a vida política mostra o contrário ambas
advogavam contra a proibição dos
direitos básicos das mulheres durante a
século 18 mais precisamente após a
Revolução Francesa pois essa trouxe à
tona o debate dos direitos políticos e
civis a população consequentemente sendo
debatido os direitos femininos e com a
constante luta com a luta de mulheres
como Eleanor Roosevelt primeira-dama dos
Estados Unidos que teve grande
importância na criação da carta
internacional dos direitos das mulheres
também como Angela Davis que aos 77 anos
continua lutando e participando
ativamente de marchas em prol dos
direitos mulheres também como linda
nochlin que publicou o artigo Por que
não houveram grandes mulheres artistas
no país no qual faz uma reflexão sobre a
não representatividade feminina no mundo
das Artes e também como escritora
favorita chimamanda adichie que através
de seus textos e falas mostra a
importância de diversas causas sociais e
faz o feminismo quando você dessas
mulheres incríveis e milhares de outras
nós conseguimos os direitos que nós
temos hoje
E agora vocês podem estar se perguntando
Marina as mulheres já tem igualdade
porque é continuar lutando e eu vou
responder a gente tem que continuar
lutando por que ainda não temos Equidade
é importante ressaltar a diferença de
igualdade e Equidade na igualdade as
pessoas recebem o mesmo tratamento na
oferta de oportunidades já na Equidade
as pessoas recebem tratamentos
diferentes para ter a mesma oportunidade
nós temos que continuar lutando por que
ainda não há Justiça no mercado de
trabalho no mercado de trabalho
brasileiro a cada um real que o homem
ganha a mulher em média ganha somente 77
centavos e-mail e esse pay GAP essa
diferença salarial aumenta a cada vez
mais de acordo com com mais poder
existência o cargo nós temos que
continuar lutando porque ainda há muita
injustiça ainda muita contrariedades no
direito das mulheres à educação
meninas em 70 países sofrem ataques por
ir é simplesmente porque alguns grupos
sociais não concordam que estas devam
ter direito à educação isso segundo
dados da ONU outro exemplo disso é que
em 2012 no Irã 77 cursos impediram o
ingresso de mulheres porque esses são
eram de natureza feminina esses cursos
incluíam química arqueologia e
Informática mas continuamos lutando os
estupros ainda aceitavam nas ilhas
caribenhas as Bahamas o marido pode
forçar relações sexuais com sua esposa
mesmo sem que ela querer desde que ela
seja maior de quatorze anos ou se
exemplo disso é que mais de 50 países
mulheres não têm autonomia sobre seus
corpos não poder podendo decidir se
querem ou não ter relações sexuais se
podem ou não tomar anticoncepcional ou
até mesmo se podem buscar atendimento
médico
com isso segundo dados do Fundo de
população das Nações Unidas nós
continuamos lutando pois o feminicídio
existe o feminicídio é o assassinato de
mulheres baseada simplesmente em seu
gênero só no primeiro semestre 2020
tivemos 648 Asus feminismo e feminicídio
isso só no Brasil
ainda depois de tantos anos de história
depois de tanta luta de tuas tanto
debate aberto ainda existem muitos
equívocos acerca desse tema muitos
homens como também mulheres afirmam que
os únicos objetivos das feministas são
serem libertinas não se depilarem e
serem superiores aos homens membros da
minha família já falaram diretamente
para mim que as feministas são
frustradas desse jeito pois não foram
pegos por um homem de verdade
e também já disseram que as feministas
só querem oprimir os homens e uma colega
da minha idade já disse que o único
objetivo das feministas eu em especial é
quebrar a tradicional família brasileira
a verdade aqui sim queremos que as
mulheres têm o direito de ter suas
sexualizadas não demonizadas e
comentadas e também queremos que não
seja tá borra mulheres se depilarem ou
não mas ninguém sabe for sendo a não se
depilar e principalmente não não
queremos oprimir ou ser superiores aos
homens até mesmo que não tem como
Oprimido oprimir opressor o feminismo
luta por diversas causas muito
importantes causas que vão ajudar no
desenvolvimento da sociedade mas muitas
pessoas preferem ignorar isso
agora Marina Como eu posso ajudar
como eu acabei de citar mulheres ainda
sofrem muitas injustiças no mundo
inteiro simplesmente por serem mulheres
mas eu não espero que você sai um desse
auditório e vamos por exemplo o
continente lutar pelos direitos das
mulheres à educação por exemplo nós
temos que começar essa luta localmente
no Nosso Bairro na nossa escola ou até
mesmo dentro da nossa própria família
Olha como eu posso fazer isso é
relativamente simples
faça barulho faça barulho quando você
virou a justiça não fica calada começa
uma conversa nas redes sociais os seus
círculos sociais Não deixa esse problema
passar batido se voluntariar ia segunda
linha organizações que protegem os
direitos das mulheres e também ONGs que
protegem mulheres
incentivem incentive e fornece apoio a
mulheres denunciarem seus abusos sexuais
seus estupros e violência doméstica e
principalmente participe participe
ativamente de marchas e Protestos e
passeatas pois essa é a melhor forma de
chamar atenção para o problema e d
mandarão uma melhora
e eu espero que nós podemos poderemos
usar esse Restart das nossas vidas esse
reinício posso pandemia para
reinicializar para ter um mundo melhor
para ser uma melhor a nossa cidade
vamos reinicializar vamos começar vamos
começar esse ano novo com a melhora
muito obrigada a
G1